many are saying that last night Super  Bowl halftime show by Jennifer Lopez and  Shakira was one of the best in years I  thought was fantastic if you didn't see  it here's just a quick clip Wow yeah  incredible it was it was fantastic  really people loved it in fact one of  our employees marina Miu knows who's in  our accounting department is still super  pumped about the halftime show  she said it filled her with pride and a  sense of female empowerment and I got to  say I really showed in her work today  [Applause]  [Music]  Sabrina you you really like the JLo  secure a halftime show it was it was so  good okay we're all glad you enjoyed it  but marina you really have to get back  to working normally around here okay  I will okay right after this  [Music]  we have a winner great show tonight star  the new movie panty glory  [Applause]  [Music]  you